this is Startalk alright let's go to Tom
Rix
our ix what a cool name John the cool
yeah I'm wrench John Rick's wants to
know this first he states today magic is
simply a word to describe an occurrence
that you didn't fully understand then it
gives an example for example I imagine
my dog Duke is completely bewildered by
my ability to change images on the TV
without touching it I think you give
your dog a lot of credit there man but
anyway he doesn't know about the
invisible signal sent from the remote so
to him it's complete magic would a
technologically superior civilization be
able to compete completely bewildered
our scientists with their technology to
the point where our scientists would
believe it's magic or is our
understanding of physics sound enough
that we would know what's up even if we
couldn't replicate it ourselves that was
a long way to go to say this Bill Nye
you as a scientist you encounter an
alien race they are able to perform what
looks like magic by violating the laws
of physics would you say it's magic or
would you say no I got to find out how
they violated the laws of physics I'd go
with the second one what I'd probably
say is there's some law of physics we
don't fully understand okay this is
something this manifestation this effect
this phenomenon is described by some
aspect of nature that we do not yet
grasped gosh' and to say that the dog
thinks it's magic when you change the
channel I'm open-minded but skeptical
yes oh man I think Duke the dog just
kind of takes it for granted yeah how
human shows up she's got food correct
once in a while he smells like a dog are
we going for a walk yeah are you another
dog we're going for a walk exactly I'm
tired do you have any food right I mean
that's I don't think did the claim that
a dog thinks it's magic God believes in
supernatural phenomena yeah I'm
open-minded but skeptical that's a
that's a bit anthropomorphic it is Jack
Danya projecting a human perceptions
that so as arthur c clarke who remark
that any sufficiently sophisticated
technology would be insufficient would
be indistinguishable from magic right
but it's a charming turn of phrase or
quotation but you start getting into the
semantics of what is magic and you can
knock yourself out I just think with 85%
of the observable universe being dark
matter right which means you can't see
it there's a lot we don't understand
people say you got all I'm saying have
to claim that that is magic supernatural
and the certain people can control this
dark matter dark energy with their minds
I have your father I'm open-minded bit
skeptical yeah there you go Tom so no
that's not the way it would work and so
the scientists would still say nope we
just don't understand how they're doing
it but it doesn't mean that it's magic
and to any animal that licks its own
testicles really doesn't care what's on
TV
so there's you know I don't know I've
seen dogs just definitely certain
programs dogs prefer isn't I mean
there's not there's no doubt it really
is an assessment of animal behavior okay
all right I don't I sound on my business
card animal behavior a B now I'm
projecting because maybe me as a dog
wouldn't care with the logic we're all
dogs I feel a little problem in
Funkadelic coming on right now in a
certain situation if I'm a dog but yes
you are the reader of the queries right
you demand now dog there you go that's
right my dog